well I said it days ago and it's now
closer to a reality Donald Trump is
considering war with North Korea
according to a fellow Republican Senator
Lindsey Graham we have talked about the
sort of erratic and volatile nature that
is increasingly a concern in terms of
Donald Trump sitting there isolated in
the Oval Office watching TV report on
the growing list of failures and
scandals and my concern and that of many
others is that there will be more
incentive for Donald Trump to take some
kind of military action North Korea
probably being at the top of the list of
candidates Syria and Iran subsequent to
that Senator Lindsey Graham now says
Donald Trump personally told him if
North Korea continues to test these
ICBMs these intercontinental ballistic
missiles there will be war here's
Lindsey Graham explaining it on NBC News
but they get a missile they can hit
California maybe other parts of America
everything every military expert says
there is no good military option but
they're wrong there is a military option
to destroy North Korea's program in
North Korea itself he's not going to
allow President Trump the ability of
this madman to have a missile to hit
America if there's going to be a war to
stop and it will be over there if
thousands die they're going to die over
there they're not going to die here and
he's told me that to my face and that
may be provocative but not really when
you're a pros in the United States where
is your allegiance lie to the people of
the United States this man kim jungnam
is threatening America with a
nuclear-tipped missile president Trump
doesn't want a war the Chinese can stop
this but to China South Korea and Japan
Donald Trump is not going to allow this
missile to be clear are you saying it's
okay to use a military option that
immediately in dangers the lives of
millions of people in that region I'm
saying is inevitable unless North Korea
changes because you're making our
president pick between regional
stability and homeland security so
Lindsey Graham appeared completely
honest and earnest here although he was
slammed for these comments today and
that they are it was alleged that they
are at odds with the views of the
Secretary of State Rex Tillerson
wouldn't be the first time Tillerson has
no clue what it is Trump has up his
sleeve now we have to split
it's into two parts there's a completely
legitimate debate to be had about how to
deal with North Korea if at all I've
been talking about it for ten years you
can talk about more sanctions when
sanctions are put in place they mostly
hurt the poor people of North Korea who
are the people that we are trying to
help
not to mention that China can easily
counter our sanctions with more aid if
they want to a surgical strike
can you really destroy what you want to
destroy fully without civilian
casualties in a surgical strike because
again part of our interest in North
Korea is a humanitarian effort and then
there's this idea of a larger military
incursion significant civilian
casualties would be experienced we again
ostensibly care about the humanitarian
crisis there affecting the North Korean
people since we do send them aid money
and food we're going to end up making
that way worse so North Korea's response
to that incursion could easily cause
loss of life among some of our allies
including South Korea Japan could be
implicated there
the real concern to me is not the
geopolitical discussions about North
Korea which we've been having for a long
time pad it's that this is where
President Trump is the biggest risk and
I have the most fears and Japan by the
way would also like to see changes in
North Korea Japanese Prime Minister
Shinzo Abe a has said he fully agrees
with Crump that China needs to be
putting more pressure on Japan and
everything is pointing now towards Trump
sitting there in the Oval Office
yelling tweets to his assistant in the
next room and watching Fox News thinking
Japan says we need to be tough on this
situation and all the reporting on TV is
about my scandals what about going into
North Korea well I mean notice how the
interviewer there said that there are no
good military options when it comes to
North Korea and Lindsey Graham responds
by saying well there are military
options that's very concerning
especially because Lindsey Graham is one
of the most hawkish members of the US
Senate that's really saying something
and the other thing concerning here too
is he's having conversations with Trump
about this and trumple ping-pong back
and forth between being a non
interventionist and saying that we have
to take out their families so he's
easily convinced I'm worried about
Graham influencing him in a negative
direction well one thing is for sure if
you want to learn about this
situation in the context of Donald
Trump's broader foreign policy ideology
good luck because there is no such thing
to the extent that the guy knows
anything about foreign policy he's taken
every position on every issue so you're
not going to really find anything too
deep there so two-sided situation one is
the facts on the ground in North Korea
and what to do and that's been a topic
for a long time the second is this Trump
cult of personality surrounding this and
the possible use of the North Korean
situation to his advantage which
historically actually often works in
order to improve approval ratings and a
desperate president is not a president
that I want making decisions about when
to use military force the video you just
finished watching was made possible by
you through the membership program you
can sign up for membership at david
pakman.com slash membership we are
viewer supported independent media you
can use the coupon code
I voted 17 for a 40% discount off of
your membership